Donald Trump as you point out in your
piece I said many times he wants to be
the CEO of the u.s.a how would this go
down if he were in fact you know yeah is
this business leader who is this man
Trump at a public company would almost
certainly be out of a job according to
management consultants and lawyers who I
talked to and asked about this and not
to mention the long history of CEOs we
have who have been ousted over even
smaller things you know the the list is
very long i was almost surprised myself
how many ceos i was able to come up with
off the top of my head who've been you
know a forced to resign or chosen to
resign after allegations about an
inappropriate relationship about remarks
about gender disparities in the office
so it is an issue that comes up a lot in
corporate America and the CEOs are out
and they're out very quickly when these
things do happen well when they when
they when they come to surface let's put
it that way yeah maybe not exactly where
they happen because there's always an
argument to write espoused by some parts
of Corporate America that it's really
nobody's business of the CEO is up to
something in his private time well and
that is increasingly changing because
CEOs do have this fiduciary
responsibility to be doing what's in the
best interest of the company and as you
said if it's it's not like you know
corporate America as puritanical and
everybody's running around completely PC
all the time but when the issues come to
light and they can put the company in a
negative light and they can hurt the
share price and they can hurt the
company's customers that's when the
board gets involved and that's where
they have some duty to take action and
there's also to mention laws about
sexual harassment and appropriate
behavior in the workplace so if it's
harassment you have a legal issue in
legal liability or if it's just
something that's you know controversial
and it puts the company a bad light then
the board has a responsibility to do
what's in the best interest of
shareholders so we've talked about
public companies you've got some like
Kevin Roberts who says something
perceived as sexist he's removed from
Saatchi and Saatchi Donald Trump of
course is the head of a private company
ahead of the Trump Organization and yet
within the strictures of that we have
not seen any commotion as a result of
what he said on that tape 11 years ago
right it certainly since he is the head
of a private company there's no board
there's our well you know there's
there's not a board that responds to
shareholders there's no independent
share
there's you know it is a private company
so it does operate under different rules
than a public company where you do have
shareholders that you have to respond to
we'll see whether or not there are
business implications for his company
and I need a story a few weeks ago that
showed there are already some business
implications for his controversial
remarks and signs that hotel visits and
visits to his property might be going
down but there is this interesting you
know double standard possibly between
the CEOs and politicians that people can
discuss and I've certainly gotten emails
this morning people saying like hey
listen why wasn't Bill Clinton fired for
what he did in the White House if he had
an affair with an intern at a company
yes he would most certainly have been
fired at a publicly traded company if
that came out that would not be
tolerated there either so you know when
Bill Clinton did it you know despite you
know the impeachment he was able to keep
his job and it's gone on to having a
second act when a CEO does it in a
public company it's much different well
how far down the managerial level does
it go at what point to become less
interesting to an investor say in terms
of whether you should be ousted or just
suspended via time well look at the
Billy Bush who also made the comments on
this tape obviously he's a high-profile
figure at NBC but he's been indefinitely
suspended by nbc/universal took that
action very quickly but once you get
further down the the food chain of the
company then there are these legal rules
if you're saying something that is
making your other employees and
comfortable that's sexual harassment
that's taken very seriously